you
Can you guys hear me through this?
Uh-oh, I think all my audio was messed up.
Hold on.
What's going on?
Output is on.
You can.
Okay.
Hold on.
Give me a second.
I don't know why.
It might be double once I fix this.
Oh, hold on.
Let me check this.
Streaming.
Streamlight.
Eh?
Uh, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do.
Brittany, thank you for the 50 gift, and thank you.
Uh, uh, uh, what the heck?
It was just working!
Oh, wait, you can hear this.
Wait.
I'm so confused.
We got the music.
I wonder...
Hold on, let's see if we can hear the game.
I think you can.
Yippee!
Hold on.
Whoops.
It's a little loud, right?
Is it, like, 7?
6, 8?
Actually, I don't know if that changed anything.
Okay.
I'm so...
The audio is low for me all around.
Yeah, but because...
Because it was lowered, because I had to turn on a different
setting.
I'm so confused.
I guess I'll just use this then.
Wait, hold on.
Let me check if it works.
Hmm.
Weird Much better Sorry if that was a jump scare Sorry if
that was a jump scare Um Okay Now I feel really weird Now I
feel all Discombobulated
Perfect volume We're good Okay I sound cleaner.
I don't know.
If I should sound cleaner.
It's all the same.
Whatever.
Bread is pain.
So true, Minecraft.
Oka-i-ni nasi-masen!
Ojo-sama!
Welcome.
Minecraft!
I am...
I truly have no plans.
Um...
I have no plans.
I'm just kind of...
And Dracos, thank you for the thank you!
I just, uh, felt like playing.
So, Amira, welcome to membership.
Thank you!
What is this new game?
I know my gosh Yeah, I'm gonna punch trees As you can see I
have no servers So So It's just gonna be You and me baby
It's gonna be just us It's gonna be single player mode All
on our own We're gonna be we're gonna be fighting for our
lives you and me together solo venture yeah a date not a
date don't say like that that's weird a date with me and
however many people are in here don't say it makes me
anxious someone is third-wheeling though one of you guys one
of you guys is third wheeling so um i have my new cat in
here with me so um at some point she might want to be let
out i don't know she's kind of doing her own thing i'm i'm
i'm i'm watching over her because she did not have a very
good morning um and i was so worried about her i thought i
would be having to take her to the vet But I think she's
okay now.
That's the new cat called Adamska.
No.
Me like being third wheel pain.
Bread is pain.
Does she have a name yet?
She does.
Hi, kitty.
She's, I don't know.
She's behind a...
I think she's...
laying in the bed over there, so...
Finally got mine grabbed.
Thank you guys for the super chats.
Thank you!
Is it MGS related?
Why?
Why would it be...
Why would it be MGS related?
MGS...
Why would it be...
Why would it be MGS related?
Motherfucking Minecraft let's go!
Sako, thanks for the pink!
First time, huh?
Playing Minecraft?
Oh, okay.
You guys, it's a bit of a fib, okay?
I'm sorry.
This isn't my first time playing Minecraft on this channel
because a couple years ago, Lyrica and Nova and I, we all
did a haunted Minecraft mod map on my channel.
So it's a bit of a lie.
I'm sorry.
I'm sorry, hold on.
I'm bowing.
I'm so sorry.
Lying is bad.
It's clickbait.
It was clickbait.
I'm so sorry.
Wait, Jabber, why you lie?
But this is the real time playing just regular Minecraft.
Yeah, I clickbaited because I'm a real YouTuber.
Let's see.
I'm excited to see what our world's going to be.
What should we call it?
That's the first thing we got to do.
What do we call the world?
Also, should I do like...
Hardcore?
Wait, this is hard.
No.
Oh, wait.
It would be hardcore.
Outer heaven.
Bustin World.
Made World.
Phantom Zone.
Outer Heaven.
Bustin Zone.
Oh.
Bustin Z!
See you on the next episode of Mid-World Outer Heaven Bust
Gen Z.
Perfect.
Good job, guys.
Oh my gosh.
Whoa.
I wonder where we're gonna start.
I hope it's somewhere good.
Cows!
You guys are in Minecraft.
Hopefully there's no lag.
That was the audio, by the way.
Just let me know.
I can change anything you want.
We're in a jungle.
Go punch a tree.
Oh, here we go.
Here we go.
Oh.
Wait, where's my...
Okay, I need four of these.
Okay.
crafting...
Oh.
Crafting table!
I want it to be nearer though.
The two by two.
Crafting table.
Okay.
Let's go explore the land a little bit.
Oh my gosh.
Okay, I can...
Oh, yes.
Check me out.
Yippee!
I'm beautiful.
I'm next to this cow.
Oh, hold on.
I don't want to fall into a hole and like die immediately,
but...
Oh my god.
Wait.
Oh, this is a water.
I was gonna say I could have fallen into a hole and died
immediately.
Who's that creeper?
Oh man.
Um...
So, uh...
Yesterday I was supposed to stream.
Oh!
I just realized my eyes.
So...
I'm always so excited when I'm running around.
But I have to open my eyes to be able to play the game, you
know.
She's a professional.
She learns so fast.
So pro.
I can't help that I'm just a gamer.
I adapt, you know.
Being a gamer is all about adapting quickly.
I don't want to go down there just yet.
We have nothing.
Am I playing?
Oh, I'm playing in hardcore mode.
Oh my gosh, I forgot.
Okay, wait, we actually need to get some stuff then, don't
we?
We actually need to get some stuff.
Like this little flower.
Today I do want to build a little maid cafe.
I want to do that.
So this game seems interesting.
it gets popular.
It's just like a little kind of indie, right?
I think.
It's a little indie.
Probably like a school project or something.
Hardcore maids.
Speaking of maids, yesterday I finished Akiba Maid Wars.
I finished the show last night.
And, um, wow.
That was oh i forgot to finish my sentence from before but
um how was it let me finish what i was saying before and
then we'll talk about it um it was uh i forgot or not i
forgot i um i did not stream yesterday so i'm streaming
today on a monday if you're watching the vod hello thank you
it might not be monday for you but um so i wanted to make up
for it for it with at least streaming today a little bit.
And, um, I just got...
Oh, no.
I just got Minecraft yesterday.
So hopefully, you guys can backseat a little bit for me if
it's okay.
Tuesday here.
It's Tuesday.
Ah!
Oh, oh, I'm dying.
Oh, God.
Um, maybe you guys should tell me that I should...
Not drown.
Oh my gosh.
It's April 29th.
Colonel, we managed to avoid drowning.
Real.
Oxygen is important.
Okay, let's make ourselves a...
The real crafting table.
I should eat.
Are there any birds around here?
Um...
but um yeah so i wanted to make up for it i don't do not
have a schedule this week that i'm writing out because my
week is kind of like a little bit weird um so uh i will is
that a skelly man in the day you're not welcome here so um
but I will be putting up waiting rooms for streams that I
have that I have confirmed for this week.
Such as I have a Metal Gear stream up for tomorrow, April
30th.
It's totally radical and cool.
Rude, he's just mining his business.
This is my business.
This is my...
I colonize this place.
It's mine.
I'm the ruler here now.
But yeah.
So radical and cool.
It's so awesome.
Another thing.
Oh, oh.
We're hungry, you guys.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Another thing I can tell you guys is Friday I have a collab.
If you watch the Hell Diver stream.
Oh.
A bird I can eat.
This is not a bird I can eat Sorry Oh Okay Um Let's eat some
cows Where Skelly and spider Bozo Wait where Why are they so
close Why are they so loud?
Okay.
Please die.
Okay, gosh.
It's just the Aurora Borealis.
What should the next world name be?
Don't say that.
Look, I'm punching you.
I'm punching pigs now, okay?
I'm punching pigs.
Doesn't this music really relax you?
During all of this.
Are they right?
Oh, shoot.
Run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run.
Okay, I saw.
Oh, God.
Ouch.
Okay.
We're fine.
Maui's idiot can't even stand the sunlight okay let's punch
some more trees but
yeah so I'll be doing a collab with Matara Henya hold on let
me actually we could we confirm this right yes Matara Henya
and Haruka on Friday for Left 4 Dead
So, don't vomit this time.
No guarantees this time.
So I'm excited for that.
That will be Friday.
8 p.m.
EST.
Oh, you guys are starting to get dark.
But yeah, I wanted to just mention that about the...
What is this?
What?
Are these guys okay?
I've never seen the wolves of this color before.
New wolf types.
They added new wolves.
What?
Really?
There are different colored wolves now.
Regional wolves!
No way.
You guys are lying.
What?
There's wolf armor too?
Oh, there's so...
cute they look like dogs it's my first time seeing them ever
wow oh gosh another one why are there skelly get get him get
him boy get him I think we should build a boat and leave
this place leave this world behind we
need bones we don't need bones oh I also have the bamboo
wood how do I make that bamboo wood block of bamboo oh no i
could only make one okay a boat i think i want to find um i
want to find cherry blossoms oh it's starting to get really
dark sayonara world
Okay.
Nothing can hurt you on the boat at night.
See, this is the most relaxing.
I'll be honest.
Okay, so this is actually music that I listen to like almost
every night.
When I'm like cleaning or winding down or anything.
You can't get me.
You can't hurt me, fool.
This is what I'm listening to at home.
Yeah.
So, Akiba Maidwar.
What is this?
Oh my gosh, a coral!
I actually really quite liked Akiba Maidwar, but the ending
was so...
Wow!
The ending was very sudden, yes!
It was very, very sudden.
I'm just gonna steal oh oh can I do I have time to steal
this I think so okay let's go see you suckers now of light
the ending was it was yeah um there's always time for theft
True.
Where are we going, I wonder?
What will we find in this world?
This spectacular Minecraft world.
This looks lit up over here.
What is it?
Oh, I think it's just more coral.
Leave that guy alone over there.
I was just listening to talk about the Russian maid on the
podcast.
Oh yeah, the podcast came out today.
If you guys didn't listen, please do.
We are silly, goofy gals.
It certainly ended.
I did not watch the show.
It's like...
I don't want to say a bittersweet end.
But it is kind of bittersweet.
I actually didn't hate it.
At first I was like super shocked.
Sorry, I'm trying not to spoil anything in case anyone's
like, I was going to watch Akiba Made War right after this.
Sure, not to spoil, but...
That was good.
I'm excited to make my summer list.
Yeah!
He's got armor on.
I need that.
Wait!
This is a mesobion.
That's mesobion.
I thought it was a village.
Um...
Hmm.
I think we could just run through this.
Steal the armor.
Hmm.
Let's carry on through.
Do you like the jazz Bozo Ranger?
I don't think there's any saxophone.
This is relaxing.
Just Minecraft sounds and jazz.
I really needed to wind down today because...
um to give you guys an idea so i got i got my cat recently
and she's so sweet and so cute do we need a bucket for the
list preferably preferably preferably when i got my cat um
it's been a it's been like a little over a week and um uh
she's kind of bad in that she will get on she's I'm training
her not to get on the counter but she currently likes to get
on the counter and you know get into things a little bit but
um hey hey don't pay attention to me maybe if I go around
this side I'm trying to get to the other side
oh my god run and um but she got into the counter last night
or she got on the counter and got into some stuff last night
um i forgot to put away butaro's food and she ate it and i
don't think she had a good reaction to it and um she was
like she threw up the most amount that i've ever seen a cat
threw up first of all which was very shocking i was like
whoa i don't even know you could you had that in you um oh
i'm trapped um but she also was like just getting poop
everywhere just just endless diarrhea and um and uh there
was like poop in her art not poop there was blood oh there
was blood in her poop and ever it was just a mess i was like
calling the emergency vet i was like what do i do and um
Yeah, so I had a bit of a morning cleaning up all that and
dealing with all of that.
So I was like, I'm just gonna, I'm just gonna take it easy.
And you know what?
Minecraft is a bit of a comfort game for me.
So it sounds like my weekend.
For you?
Out your butt?
But, um, I think she's better now.
What did I walk into?
afterlife.
But that's why she's hanging out with me.
Eek!
That's why she's hanging out with me in here.
We're just, you know...
Yeah.
That happened to my new kitten.
Turns out she was having with issues with chicken.
Switch to no poultry diet.
She has been healed.
I think that's it!
Mona Pandera!
I think that's it because I feed Butaro chicken.
But I've been feeding her beef.
And then she ate the chicken and then she went crazy.
Isn't that right?
Isn't that right, little girl?
It's so sweet.
She's so sweet, though.
Beef.
They smell like beef.
Wow, the open sea is under the moonlight.
What's over here?
Could it be another jungle?
Could it be a swamp?
The world...
Just like that.
Uh-oh.
Oh, guys, we're in trouble.
Oh, we're in trouble.
No, we're not.
Nah, we're fine.
But what's her name?
Her name is
please her name is drum roll please that's her name actually
so every time i can talk about her that was not me by the
way um every time i talk to her out about her i can say drum
roll please
she's the most well experienced entrance cat ever to ever
have an entrance drum roll please drum roll please is such a
cute name thank you i thought so too
wow actually okay i'll tell you for real her name is drum
roll please
drum roll please
You already said that.
More drums!
I want a whole...
I want a full...
Band.
I want a whole percussion.
I want everyone who owns a drum.
To use it right now.
We gotta go murder some more animals, I think.
Perfect.
Beef is back on the menu.
I don't know why I'm so embarrassed telling you her name.
It's not even that, like, embarrassing.
Oh, wait.
I should save this.
Okay, I'm gonna death by flower.
Come on.
Stand still.
What?
What is wrong with you?
There we go.
Perfect.
I should really...
I should really make a sword.
Okay.
Drum roll, please!
Her name is Paz!
Get it?
Because it's like cat paws, but it's Paz.
Isn't it cute?
Actually?
Right?
It's actually cute.
Actually, her name is Pacifica Ocean, but you know.
Sword.
I thought about, um, what's the word?
Speed running stuff.
Or trying to, attempting to speed run.
But, um.
For today's stream.
But, uh, I don't know.
I thought.
maybe you guys weren't ready for that kind of challenge yeah
that is kojima level naming convention
i don't know if she wants peace though so it's even truly
more fitting
it's a little too intense for us yeah pyes is also peace in
spanish yeah That's why Paz is Paz in Metal Gear.
I'm sorry, I gave my cat a Metal Gear name.
But you have to understand.
It's...
You have to understand who you're dealing with right now.
Is it Paz?
Like P-A-W-Z?
Or Paz?
P-A-Z?
It's just P-A-Z.
P-A-Z.
Whoa, that's...
That's water?
Whoa!
It looks so awesome.
The reflection of it.
If you're wondering, I'm using complementary shaders.
Wait, so will we see other wolves as well here?
Game looks nice.
It's the complementary...
The...
Complementary.
Something.
There's like a little tagline after it.
I don't remember.
Shaders.
No, more than Shaders.
It was like reloaded.
Matrix Revolution loaded.
Watching you play Minecraft, it just feels so right.
All right, words can't express the feeling of comfort I have
right now, even though I've never played it on this channel.
That's good though.
Feel comfort.
Wait, maybe we can get some, what's it called in here?
I need some, we need some stone.
But we also need some coal.
Played it once.
You're so right.
Sorry.
I can't even remember my own lore.
I used streamer.
I used to watch also use complimentary shaders.
I looked through the Minecraft setting for such a long time
before I realized that didn't mean the shaders were called
complimentary.
Wait, what do you mean?
If you Google complimentary shaders Minecraft, I'm pretty
sure you'll get these, right?
Are you ever going to play with mods?
Yes!
I would like to.
Sorry, I just didn't set it up this time.
We're like super bare bones today.
But in the future, there will be mods and stuff of the like.
Yes, yes.
I went to May Dreaming for the first time and second time
recently.
It was amazing.
I can't wait to come back and when I go to Japan, Oh my
gosh, generic user!
Glad you liked it.
Maybe we can find a village and pillage their food.
Be on the lookout for some coal, everybody.
Use your little wispy eyes.
I used my eyes!
Oh my gosh, I can't believe I saw that!
Escape route, boop.
No one here?
Good deal.
Oh, yeah.
You guys were no help.
More.
We tried.
I thought about putting on a playlist of Minecraft music
instead.
But I don't know why some of the Minecraft music comes off
very unsettling.
Some of it's just, like, kind of weird.
you know some of it's like a little bit creepy self-help is
the best help hi Amori
let's get out of skedaddle skedaddle I oh I said get out of
here and skedaddle let's get out of here let's get get out
of here let's get out now we can cook our
Meats.
But...
Looking for a village, but I don't say you will.
Get out of.
Hmm.
I went to find Cherry Blossoms.
That's where I will settle.
I used to do Minecraft plus Animal Crossing.
I was like, oh, that sounds like a good combo, too.
Minecraft is a horror game hiding behind adventure.
Yeah, I guess that's why, right?
The music is a little weird.
Hey, Minty, do you know what tomorrow is?
Tomorrow.
This is something special.
We are on a quest.
We are!
A Minty quest.
Oh!
I knew there'd be a village.
come on pillage pillage pillage the village oh what are you
what oh what I'm a I'm a dillo what wait can I take him how
could do I pick you up wait what What did they like to eat?
An armadillo!
When did they add this?
When did they add these?
Oh, they sell... Hold on, I want to hear what they sound
like.
The other day?
Wait, what do you mean the other day?
These are brand new?
Oh my god, they're so cute.
What is your purpose?
what why do you exist what that is a chonker don't fall in
there can they swim look at him go this purpose is to be
silly so true oh my gosh first we got the wolves what what
else is new oh my gosh it's like i'm playing minecraft again
for the first time which is today hello i'll take that
mine you have no job
i was gonna say a functioning village but not quite
Their purpose is to be slaughtered to make armors for dogs.
I know you're lying.
Don't say that.
Wow.
I'm stealing your food.
Wait, is that gonna...
How's it doing that?
How's your water just sitting there like that?
How's that happening?
Potion?
Do you have any beds?
Like, where do you...
Where do you rest?
Whoa!
Heck yeah.
Can't see anything.
Where do you sleep?
Did I?
Oh, up there probably.
How'd they get up there?
In here maybe?
No.
Is that like a temple?
Cool.
Might be better now.
The shader...
This shader night darkness is crunchy with the video
compression.
Oh no, really?
Take that.
Thank you.
May you never have a restful night again.
Solidus.
Crunchy.
Good morning, world!
Good morning, Minion.
Delicious.
Food that's not made by me is awesome.
You know?
Oh, ha minto!
Oh, ha minto.
Oh, bloop, bloop, bloop, bloop.
I think I'm going to steal that armadillo.
But also, I'm curious if I kill him what happens.
I'm curious about...
Death.
I'm killing.
She said the thing.
There they go!
You can do it!
Just press space!
Oh!
You almost made it.
Uh-oh!
Whoa!
Are we good?
Are we back?
That wasn't YouTube.
I said OBS disconnected for a second.
Windows noises.
We're back?
That was so weird.
Surprised me even.
Classic OBS.
I won't tell you that that slip up to recover from a...
Wait.
that slip up to recover from a death don't worry what are
you talking about what are you talking about huh i'm alive
and i'm healthy and well i'll never die in this game i'm
already dead i'll never die in game i've never died in game
before don't use that opportunity to create a montage of
every
What's going on?
Why do I keep disconnecting?
We're back?
Turtle, thanks for the super.
Super chat.
Let's just saw, will you play with Henya?
She loves Minecraft.
Yeah!
I want to play with Henya.
Armadillo!
Where?
He's rolling.
Oh!
Oh my god, I thought he was a...
If I run past them, they roll up?
Stop, that's so cute.
Kick him.
Play soccer.
I'm playing soccer with this armadillo until my OBS is
better.
you run past them they just curl up into a little tiny ball
how did he get all the way down there did he roll can they
roll what he was just up here right I'm not crazy there's no
other guy you
kicked him I didn't kick I didn't kick him okay I'm gonna
commit a crime.
Oh, Armadillo shields himself.
Armadillo peaks.
Oh, hold on.
Leave the poor things alone.
You guys said it's for armor.
They didn't drop anything.
Oh, dog armor.
My bad.
I should have done that when OBS disconnected.
I should have taken the chance when OBS disconnected to be a
real criminal.
Does that make you feel powerful?
It made me feel...
I'm not quite sure how I feel right now.
I do feel a little bit evil.
And I like that feeling.
Add it to the list of crimes.
Crimes!
I have no list of crimes, you guys.
I'm a ghost maid.
I know I just finished watching Akiba Maibor in those games.
In that series, they're all criminals, but not me.
Dang.
Let's go punch some more wood.
Actually, no, I think we're good.
We might...
We might even be able to make stone.
You're a simp.
Me?
I'm a simp?
Did you see Kojima's tweet about saying not being his first
choice for the ending song of Peace Walk?
Really?
No, I didn't see that actually.
What was his first choice?
It was probably something too expensive.
go away
he didn't say but sing was so perfect people are saying it
was imagine no sing what I can't imagine I can't imagine it
being anything other than sing
I don't want to imagine another song or I'll cry I can see
it being imagined.
What?
What is imagined?
Is that Elton John?
Oh, there's a fire.
Imagine all the people.
No, see, it doesn't fit the vibe.
Wait, that's the Beatles, right?
Oh, John Lemon.
Imagine dragons.
Lennon.
Nice.
No!
It burned!
My food burned.
The beagles.
No, I said the beetles.
For what purpose?
To have a fried chicken.
Duh.
Think smarter, not harder.
Thanks for coming back, Mint.
You're welcome.
I could have just, I could have, I should have taken the
opportunity to book it.
I should have taken the opportunity to run.
Mint, you've changed.
This is what Minecraft does to you.
It turns you into a psychopath, I think.
No, I've always been the same.
I've always been the same.
Think smarter, not harder.
What?
What do you mean?
That's a real phrase!
Right every... Oh gosh.
We're okay.
That's a real phrase.
It means...
It means think smarter, not harder.
something because it's easier.
Work smart.
Wait, what do you mean?
What did I say?
Oh!
I'm thinking harder, you guys.
Maybe I do need to think harder.
What did she mean by this?
I don't think!
I don't know!
I don't even think.
We're gonna go find some place to sleep tonight.
Someplace I won't be disturbed.
What is this?
Rock formation.
Lava!
Shiori!
Thank you for the 50 gifted!
Thank you!
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Okay, I think we can sleep on top of this tiny block.
Here's my...
Ben.
Put it down.
Nice.
Woohoo!
Alrighty.
I'm back on my...
Bullspit.
Oop!
For everybody who's like coming in, they're like, what's she
doing?
I'm, I don't know what I'm doing.
I'm playing.
I'm playing Minecraft.
Sorry, should I have said your full name?
Shiori Novella Novelite.
Wait, it's blocked off the rest of it.
Hold on.
I can't see your name, but thanks for the gift in.
Let's go this way.
Next village we find, we're going to bring them the gift of
maids.
A maid cafe.
In their area.
This area kind of sucks.
Dolphins!
I'm so...
What else?
Wait, okay.
What else have they added in the Minecraft then?
If they added armadillos and they added...
Uh, what else have they added with the wolves?
Maybe we can go on a hunt for that.
Camels.
Music.
They got burgers now!
They added the deep dark.
I've been there before.
I just, uh, you know, we can go.
It's just, you know, I'm too cool for the deep dark.
They added some new discs.
The guns!
Burgers.
Wait, really?
Burgers?
First we have Shiori.
Now we have Narissa Ravencroft's All I say is S!
Her Ravencroft's!
Thank you.
Thank you for the five gifted.
Oh my gosh.
I can't believe Advent's watching my stream.
Oh my goodness, what an honor.
Fire, fire, light the fire.
Dancing to the...
Something, something!
All right, thank you for the vibe, gifted thank you.
They added circles.
Don't lie to me.
This is Minecraft.
We need Bibu and Flamoko.
No.
I think you have to stick your gut out now.
Will that summon Bebu?
Oh.
Wow, how lucky!
I just stopped here, but I think it's actually a spot.
I think it's actually a nasty spot.
For nasty people.
Oh, I don't want to die here.
By drowning.
Wait, I'm going to become one of them!
Oh gosh.
That was close.
Coming out, idiot!
Don't you know how to leave?
Is there...
Is there anything in here?
I can't see.
Oh wait.
Mon-han.
Maybe there's a chest.
I don't have a thing to get the sussy sand if there is any.
That's a sussy sand.
What's wrong with me?
Oh god.
Oh.
Uh-oh.
There's another fire over there, you guys.
Everything's setting on fire.
Oh my god.
Koseki, Vibu, Sparkling Platinum, Jan of Hololivey, and
thank you for the 10 gifted.
Oh, here, I was going to do this.
Sticking out your gut for real is...
Wait, Ne Rizzler.
Your soapy bootacks.
Oh, is there anything in here?
I don't want to destroy the Sussie.
Oh, oh, no!
I can't open it.
I have to destroy the sussie sand.
How do we make the thing?
Hmm.
Um.
How do we make, uh...
Sussie...
No.
Um.
Copper and feathers.
What's it called, though?
Oh my god.
Flower, mochoko, top doggy, holy.
Defenders, thank you for the 50k.
Thank you.
Oh my gosh, Advent!
We got them all!
I feel like...
I feel like the Pokemon Master right now.
The Infinity Stones.
Welcome to membership.
Thank you so much.
What is this thing called?
Um, sand?
No.
Brush.
What's it called?
Maybe I haven't unlocked it yet, so I can't see it.
Maybe I haven't unlocked it, so it won't show me this.
But let's go find some...
Some...
I think there probably will be some over here.
Copper.
Get bibu tags.
Uta no!
Welcome to membership, thank you!
Oh, no, that's iron.
Actually, we need this, though.
How can
I go plant this?
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, perfect.
People, welcome to membership.
Thank you.
Alan Chocobo, welcome to membership.
What's this, what's this, oh, my goodness.
Oh my gosh.
We are actually playing.
the game now is kind of crazy.
Okay.
Welcome to membership!
Take!
Does it mean you're kind of Captain Planet now or something?
Oh.
With my five powers combined, I'm Captain Planet!
How'd that song go?
Actually, don't remember how the Captain Planet song used to
go.
I didn't see this went live ah hello i'm captain planet
captain planet he's a hero gonna take pollution down to zero
gonna something plunder and go to village he will plunder
take everything till they surrender did not rhyme brush oh
oh oh oh oh oh feather we need a feather Oh my gosh.
There's gotta be chickens around here.
Oh, I don't know why I even thought that would be...
There's gotta be chickens here.
There's gotta be chickens.
We're playing hardcore mode, you guys.
If I die, we'll never know what's in those hands.
We'll never know.
That'll be my light.
get my bed.
I'm gonna go get my bed.
So we can, when it gets actually dark, we can sleep.
Thank you for the silver chat.
I need bread.
I should also make my meat.
I'm gonna go make my meat instead of copper.
Okay.
Rekushiya.
Welcome to membership.
Thank you.
Meat.
Alright, let's go look for a chicken.
I just need one damn chicken.
One damn chicken!
I need two damn chickens.
Did I get it?
Oh, here, here, here, here, here, here.
Run!
Oh, it's getting dark out.
Wait, I'm scared.
Oh, I can sleep.
Now you can feed Paz.
No!
I don't think she can have chicken!
I think she's allergic to chicken.
Oh, brush.
back nice okay it's my okay okay sussie sand destroy sussie
sand get stuff from the temple you
just have to train her oh gosh uh Okay, I have a shovel.
I have a shovel.
Use your shovel.
Mint, what is wrong with you?
Why would you, why, VTuber, why would you use your shovel
when you have...
Treasure map.
An emerald!
Oh, thank goodness this is not any further deeper.
Or we'd be so done, though.
Did I make...
Oh, yeah, I heard this.
Undersea treasure.
Treasure, treasure.
Greetings from the Redmond side of Mojang.
Welcome back.
Thanks.
Huh?
From Mojang?
Real?
Nah.
I can never tell when people are pulling my leg, you know?
What a peculiar map.
Mr. Mojang himself.
Let's see.
What can I get rid of?
My dirt is really important.
But I think...
We'll put it like that.
People need to know someone's been here.
I will become the hero brine of this world.
Take my food.
Um, a mint-merled...
Yes.
Papita, thank you for the vibe.
Gifted.
Thank you so much.
Yeah, I'm going back for my stuff in here.
No worries.
But also, we have more...
Oh, shoot.
Hurry, hurry, hurry, hurry.
Hurry, hurry, hurry.
More sussie, sussie, sussie.
What is that?
Gold?
Gold.
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
Down.
Any more?
Oh, here.
You know, you say put a door underwater to breathe.
Like you're some kind of genius or something.
You know, like you're some kind of like, you know, that
knows you know this is this is the thrill you know the
thrill of maybe not making it back I gotta feel like I might
die in the ruins okay like that hmm what a thrill you and
Murphy were bad influences on me and now I'm officially
importing a brand new Vuelix arcade cabinet from Japan I
don't to be a bad mourner why did we get such a sad a sad
one oh yeah let's make the rest of our copper we don't
really need it but okay
somebody died me oh my gosh we can put it in the maid cafe
we can put it in the meat cafe perfect alrighty let's get my
pottery I mean my actually I am gonna take this here hurry
please axe the little axe that could please please axe
I don't think I got it what can I have written loops
that was close that was close that was close see the thrill
the thrill of death knocking at your door remembers
that a door is your no no you don't want the door we're
we're we're doing it oh oh i don't mean that what did i just
throw Where's my...
Oh.
What am I grabbing?
Where's my...
How did that even get out there?
I threw my brush.
Where is the...
Why isn't it picking it up?
Uh...
You guys?
I have an empty spot.
Oh, I somehow got rotten flesh.
Ghost chest.
And my...
my bamboo is missing too.
That's what I was trying to say earlier.
Where's the bamboo?
Kargura Chambut...
Chambut Association.
Thank you for the...
Thank you for the birthday gift.
You dropped the bamboo for space earlier in the diving.
Did I?
No, I thought I put it in the chest.
Did I not?
Did we lose the bamboo?
It's okay.
It was just one.
Let's go treasure hunting.
Surely we'll find something good.
Dangling.
There was a whole bamboo block.
Yeah, that's what I thought, right?
But it disappeared!
So strange.
Maybe I am getting a hero brined.
By fire charge.
We're gonna take that back.
We're gonna transfer all of...
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Don't burn it!
Turning all of this into wood.
I ate it.
Oh my gosh, I thought that was a person.
This scared me.
No.
So weird that it wouldn't pick up the chest earlier.
Here, O'Brien.
Okay.
Let's go get us a treasure.
Was it in the mood?
We are, okay, we're north east.
We need to go north.
No, south.
We are north.
Come on.
we are north no we are fighting dreamers actually we are
fighting a dreamers fighting a dreamers see it's next to the
10 gifted why is everybody gifting so much today what is
going on
we're going off into the sunset
oh maybe we're should go to sleep.
Let's go sleep over here.
Actually, no.
Part of the thrill is digging the treasure when you could
die.
Oh, I'm spanking off.
Oh, hee hee.
Ducky, thanks for the... Wow!
Oh, gosh.
Thanks for the five gifts so much fighting dreamers we are
fighting dreamers i've never watched naruto fighting
dreamers id number one wait what does that mean id number
zero oh pair me maybe because i'm holding wait Huh?
Remax thinks we're the gift deck.
Okay.
Yeah, fine.
Here's a super chat instead.
I didn't ask for that either.
Are we going the wrong way?
West.
South.
Saka.
Oh my god.
Jilly duchies.
I think we gotta go through the land though.
Alright, time to fight for our lives.
Actually, I'm just gonna go to sleep.
Thanks, new ring.
Uh-oh.
Are we gonna die?
Hey!
It's daytime!
Oh my god.
It's roll!
Did you guys get scared?
Don't get scared.
Everything was under control.
I had it all under control.
See,
just listen to peaceful music.
Actually I am going to turn my game down just a wee bit.
How are you still alive?
Why is he glowing?
Oh my god, it's still so loud.
Spiders can spawn with buffs?
Oh, there's another guy.
Wait, this guy has armor.
Wait, I gotta need you.
Give me your stuff.
Dang.
Why do you have buffs?
What are his buffs?
Anyway, where were we going?
Oh, no, we're past it.
We need to go north.
And then, we need to go west.
This way?
Hiya!
Wait a minute.
doing it?
No, this way.
This way?
No?
I'm confused.
My feet hurt.
Are we there yet?
I think I'm lost.
More west.
This way.
This way is west.
This is like the most west we could go.
Absolute west.
this way no this way more West oh are we almost there no I
don't think so what are your favorite mods for Minecraft
what mods do you enjoy the most got your nose um what are
you talking about Let them mess him.
Wait, I'm in my boat.
Like this.
Wait.
Paz!
Can you guys hear her?
Paz, come here!
Come here, come here!
I think she wants out.
She's a...
She's kind of a...
Are you yawning?
I thought there was something in the game, but it was her.
She's so, so cute.
I know.
Come here, boys.
Come here, come here.
She doesn't listen very well, though.
Want this whole time?
Let's have my tongue out.
Come here.
Stop honking.
Hold on.
I'm going to try.
Come here, come here, come here.
She doesn't listen very well.
I don't think she like...
No.
Come here.
Yeah, you see the speaker.
Girl, you sweet girl.
Yes, you are.
Okay, she just wants out.
Hold on.
Give me one second.
I think she opened the door.
But I think she's hungry.
So do you guys mind if I, like, feed her real quick?
Give me, like, two seconds to go feed my cat.
Okay, I'm so sorry.
You get some sweet jazz moments.
Give me one second.
I'm just going to feed her real quick.
I'm so sorry.
I'm back.
I grabbed some snacks for me, too.
I, uh, I have no idea how she opened the door.
Because I shut it.
It's so weird.
Anyway.
Clever girl.
She is clever.
Hmm.
Wait, I was so close.
wait i was so close what are we cronching sorry i got like a
little um i got i'm i have some snacks still from when i was
in japan so i was eating that a little bit
north east north It's not in the water though.
Is it?
Weast.
West.
This way.
This way?
Ember please.
Maybe.
Maybe you can get lucky and so we'll gift it but fortunately
I can't.
tell you other but it's okay you don't have to member don't
worry about it
village here
please don't break
oh nice
paperbacks thanks for the vibe gift and thank you
I must.
I don't want anyone ever to feel like they have to, um, you
know, do something to, like, support me, you know.
Oh, iron sword!
Let's go, baby!
Let's get some food.
You know what?
Maybe I don't need the wool.
Hard to see.
I don't think we really need.
We don't really need.
Take that, though.
Take that.
And that.
Oh, wait.
Is this the same map?
Yes.
So we can get rid of the maps, too.
Very good.
Speaking of JP's next Jaggerico, crunchy or stale?
Crunchy.
I think.
Willzy!
Thanks for the five gifted.
Thank you.
I don't know.
I used to be a Jagger B fan because, like, I thought it was
a little softer and I kind of like that.
But, um, I mean, I thought they are softer than Jagariko.
But now I'm kind of more for the Jagariko.
Mmm.
But for a long time, for a long, long time, I was always for
the Jagabee.
Which do you like?
Jagariko or Jagabee?
Umami flavors high quality too.
Kathleen, thanks for the tiny gifted!
Jagabee, Jagabee, Jagarico, Jagarico.
Haven't had either.
No Japanese snacks for me.
Surely you can find some place that has some Japanese
snacks.
I've wanted to sign up for like a...
I don't know.
Some sort of like, whoa!
What's going on here?
Some sort of Japanese snack service because...
Oh, it's a whole lot of nothing.
Nevermind.
Because, I don't know, it's just kind of fun to like, to
anticipate something in the mail.
You know what I mean?
Like a monthly like, oh, I'm gonna...
Is that a graveyard?
I use box.
I've heard of box.
I've never used it before, though.
How about blue?
Bread!
Spruce.
but um
but uh they're kind of expensive so I've never signed up for
one will you open up a PO box uh I don't really have plans
to at the moment um oh my god there's more fire everywhere
we go i think hero brain actually is following us
a trick to the japanese stores in manhattan that's so
awesome
yeah um i don't really plan on opening up a p.o box because
i would have to probably manage it myself and i don't know
what if i get something weird and then
um maybe hopefully hopefully I mean I would like a manager
and then maybe if I once I get a manager whenever that time
comes um I wouldn't be so a throne I don't I don't know like
I really don't I would I only really want a PO box for
people to send me oh my god we have a prison or only if
people like wanted to send letters right like I don't want
people to feel like they're having to buy me things and I
don't really I don't even know what I would put on a throne
I kind of already have everything that I want I don't really
need it's kind of like when my mom is like what do you want
for your birthday or Christmas I'm like I don't know I have
everything that I need toilet paper
more arcade cabinets i went to an electronics store the
other day
and they had um they had like tiny wheel of fortune cabinets
and tiny uh they had other ones what was it um they had tiny
wheel of fortune oh tiny the the buck the buck wild buck
hunting go wild add that too.
Gem D, thanks for the 10 gifted.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
You can get the TMNT arcade cabinet.
Brilliant.
Book wow.
Is that what it's called?
Look at that kit.
Wow, this village is nice it's really popping like we are
good on food he's a scholar skyripo thank you for the five
gifted thank you oh my gosh this one's two stories wait oh
nice wow this is a really nice It's huge!
I don't think I've ever seen a village this large before.
Rich man house.
Not up to code, but that's okay.
Rich no more.
Ouch!
Enjoy this mint-colored super chat.
Oh my gosh, Gavin!
Hi, Gavin.
Thank you.
What the heck?
Where's my boat?
Uh-oh.
The man himself.
This guy made me move.
Oh, you get out.
Did I take my boat?
Did I leave it over here?
Where did I leave it at?
Chimji, thank you for another 10 counted.
Thank you.
Oh, here it is.
Alright, continuing onward.
Wait a second.
Didn't I say the next village we come across will build them
a maid cafe?
We'll show them the wonders of maid?
Yeah, make the maid cafe here.
Yeah, I said that, didn't I?
Okay, we're gonna make it right here in the town center.
Oh, okay.
I'm already getting opposition to our maid cafe, but that
will not deter me.
I'm already receiving threats.
Divine intervention.
He would love to see a maid cafe outside his house.
I'm just saying.
That would be his number one priority.
Flagship Cafe.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Now, the thing about this maid cafe is we can only make it
with stuff that we already have.
So, um...
So, it might be a place that only a mother could love.
Oh, my God.
I thought that was a Skelly, man.
Budget cuts?
Pretty much.
Until we get more patrons, we are flat broke.
We eat seaweed every day.
Let's set up a
furnace.
Okay.
and i'm gonna start burning this actually like that okay as
a fellow ghost have you been watching the space ghost coast
to coast live on youtube i'll be honest i actually watched a
couple episodes i did i actually watched it just a little
bit but i never watched space ghost before so um but it's
been showing up in my feed so like i'm like yeah you know
Maybe I will watch some space ghost coast to coast.
Made ghost coast to coast.
Love space ghost.
I always liked, um...
Uh, I never had watched it, but I always liked the little...
The little...
Bug guy.
What's his name?
But it's funny because I had watched a Zorak.
Yeah, actually wait.
There's the other guy.
I don't know how to describe what he said.
How do you look so?
The hysterical laughter of mint makes my day better.
What do you mean by that?
The other guy.
Moltar?
Hold on, I'm gonna look him up.
Mol.
The guy that has the sharp teeth.
He's so cute.
The Zorak.
What's the guy?
Not the guy in the suit.
Brak?
Maltar's cool, though.
Yes!
He's so cute!
Why do you already have diamonds?
What's the thing?
A certain developer gifted me.
The odds are in my favor.
Oh,
let's just say my dad works at Mojang.
We're gonna have to mix and match, baby.
This is the first store.
It's very small.
But that's because we only have, like, one person working
here.
but um oh we have lots of spruce we have so much spruce but
i have an idea for this watch watch watch how cute this is
gonna be where's my shovel
it broke um what you call me look i may be having hard times
but Just flat out saying I'm broke is really, you know.
Like, I get out my situation, okay?
They told me on Twitter to stop buying candles, but I
just...
Oh, down!
See, it's already shaping up really well, right?
And then it's going to be a double door here.
Made of a mysterious wood.
Door.
Made of...
No, I don't want spruce.
I want them to be able to see and see what they're missing
out on.
Made of a jungle.
Yes.
The eating Mike Tyson's eyes Now The Hero 5 Gifted Thank you
Are you guys seeing the vision?
You guys are seeing the vision I know it Oops Actually this
is where we keep This is where we keep our money
What is that emoji?
What was that person's face?
Thank you.
Real yaggle.
Very real.
Thank you.
Bat chest?
What is that?
It's a Twitch emoji.
Oh
Now we have lots of glass.
Oh, you're good
Who what's the emote of wait bat bat chest
Who is that Who is that
A legend.
There's too many legends.
You know?
You can't call everybody a legend because then nobody's a
legend.
You can't call everybody a legend, you guys.
There's only one legend.
No.
If you could only have one legend.
Who are you picking?
Turtle chirps?
Since when do turtles make noise?
Mint phantom.
I'm the legend.
Minecraft.
Steve.
You're the big legend.
I can only the world doesn't need any more legends.
Does Mint a skinny legend?
Possibly.
Um, we're not open yet, sir.
You guys, this town was craving a maid cafe.
They're foaming at the mouth for this place.
They're ready to be served.
Maybe we should have a turtle.
Oops.
Uh-oh.
We might have to do an open-air concept.
Oh, I have one here, too.
I'm ready to serve.
A glass roof?
Good idea.
Okay.
Do you guys see the vision?
What are you serving?
A knuckle sandwich.
I thought
I had more stuff.
Serve turtles.
What do you think we're...
Inhumane?
Imagine a bank run by me.
Let's call it a paid cafe.
More like...
More like you're you they take your money.
Cafe.
Sorry if you don't know where I was going with that one.
Very intuitive.
Go go up.
Thank you.
Why do you guys watch me?
Oh, my shaders.
Oh, no!
Oh, no.
Please, please, please, please.
Please, you gotta help me!
You gotta help me!
Sir, sir.
I heard you leave.
Please.
Oh, my gosh.
This place needs me.
I wonder that myself.
I wonder that every single day of my afterlife.
I wonder every single day.
Fire, fire, light the fire.
Precisely for this.
Does it make you... Does it build your confidence a little
bit?
Are you just like, gosh.
I'm not as dumb as that, girl.
rainforest cafe.
I mean, it's a maid cafe.
It can be any theme that we'd like it to be.
What are you doing out here?
This is the jungle.
This is... what are you talking?
This is the Russian jungle.
Get out of here!
You're gonna die!
Did I get these places?
I can't remember what I've robbed and what I haven't.
Oh my god.
This useless out here.
Living off the land, not paying his taxes.
Not even with a job.
Make it a rainforest.
Okay!
Get rid of him.
Where is he?
Where'd he go?
Oh, a cat!
Where did he go?
I feel called out?
No, you're perfectly fine.
Because you're- oh, oh!
If a tree falls in a forest and no one's around, does it
make a sound?
Like how he's getting mad at me?
Can't get mad at me.
You have no job!
You guys, we have to...
Oh, he...
Actually, maybe we could have made...
Like hired him at the maid cafe.
Maybe we should have...
Maybe we could have hired him at the maid cafe.
You killed a potential customer or employee.
Make babies!
Where do you...
Oh, good, good, good, good, good.
They already have a baby.
No?
What do you mean you disagree?
With bread?
Take it.
All right.
Make babies, make babies.
Oh, here we go, here we go, here we go, here we go.
Oh, yes!
Oh my god.
Babies, babies, babies, babies, babies, babies, make babies,
make babies, make babies, make babies, make babies, make
babies, make babies, make babies, make babies, make babies,
I need more customers!
Huh?
Why won't you populate?
This guy is so stupid.
No, make a baby.
Make a baby.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh.
Brett, breed, breed, breed, breed, breed, breed.
Breathe.
Oh my god.
Wait.
Oh.
Oh my god.
It's happening.
Where is it?
Ah!
Wait, there's more trapped people.
How many people are trapped in these things?
Be free.
There you go.
Wait, this village is actually popping off.
Mint the voyeur.
Don't do it.
I only have 25.
I can't repair you every time.
There you go.
Let's see.
This guy too.
And the cat.
Okay.
This is your first time playing Minecraft.
Well, technically, it's like my first time playing the
normal Minecraft.
You know what I'm saying?
Oh my gosh.
What?
This baby took my bed!
How dare.
You're working for me.
Hold on.
Okay, hold on.
No, no, no, come back.
Uh-oh.
Wait, that's gonna catch on fire.
Maybe not.
Oh!
I don't have a way to break this.
How did they get out?
I don't think I have a way to break.
My obsidian.
Wait, wait.
Okay, hold on.
Get in there.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Kid, kid, kid, kid, kid, kid.
He'll be back.
You'll be back, Lemon.
You'll be back.
Okay.
We don't have time to worry about this kid right now,
though.
We have a main cafe to build.
He's wary of my ways?
Nah.
I want him to work for me.
He's an orphan.
His parents are dead, probably.
No joke, you just made my mantis egg hatch.
What did I...
Am I a mom?
Huh?
How did I...
How did that happen?
Huh?
Is that a euphemism?
I don't...
I don't know.
Huh?
Am I a mom?
Oh, he's a cartographer now.
He's working right here.
Okay.
We might have to have a glass roof and not in like the you
know break the glass ceiling kind of way.
But I'm going to put pumpkins on each corner for a little
bit of flair in our in our
in our rainforest mid cafe mother
he posted literal praying mantis eggs he is being as literal
as it is possible to be but what did I do to cause this was
it my charm did they say like oh my god Who is this sweet,
angelic voice we hear?
We must be born so we can identify the cause of this.
Yes.
You have that fertile aura.
Let's not say it like that.
I am not Chihuahua.
I am Fuawa.
I am not Fuawa.
I am Makuko.
Together we are Fuamoko.
Wow, wow.
Don't push me.
This is my house.
What happened to you again?
Why is nobody visiting yet?
Oh, well, we don't have any tables or anything.
It's okay.
We'll have it soon.
No worries.
There are no maids.
Not yet.
Not with that attitude.
Am I nothing to you?
Am I not a maid?
I'm right here.
Build it and they will come.
Okay.
Thank you for your wise wisdoms.
only mate I want, mate.
Stop it.
I'm just gonna take these back if you're not gonna use them,
you know?
I'm just gonna take those back if you're not gonna use them.
What will you serve in the cafe?
Good question.
Mate, I interest you in salmon.
Freshest in the sea.
Or perhaps...
Perhaps...
Priest.
Just a little priest.
Oh, oh, I almost fell through.
Don't say it.
Please not him.
He's too gummy.
Gummy kid.
Start up in armory so you can have plenty of armaments.
She's gonna serve humans.
Um, yeah, I am.
I'm serving them as my masters.
Duh.
Wow!
Oh my gosh, now I can watch how the goings on in the maid
cafe are.
from above.
Kiwawa and Hinyo were both serving something recently.
I won't say it!
You can't make me!
You can't make me say it!
You can't!
I won't.
You won't catch me saying it.
You won't catch me!
But it's okay if my Oshi say it.
me my oh she's can say whatever they want there oh wait how
do we oh we need to get some clay right for um our sherd oh
surely there is some down here
oh she's are without flaw or blame exactly exactly that's
why it's okay if they say it
Are we gonna be here?
As a woman, I finally saved the last $5 for my rent.
Now I can not get kicked out.
Don't send it to me then!
My cunt is sad now.
Who?
Why are you talking in third person like a weirdo?
Wait, is it this one?
What?
you know Mike
some things
some things are just really hard to remember but sometimes
as a streamer there are things that you must remember and I
fell I broke that rule
I I
My man Mike is important to me.
I'd never forget about him.
That guy ruined my life.
My afterlife even.
Oh, I think I'm...
Ah!
Oh god!
Oh no!
I
died because of Mike Hunt.
It's all your fault.
Mike!
Why would you do this to me?
You...
Oh, my...
The maid cafe!
Wait.
They just disappeared.
What happened?
Oh, here they are.
You!
Where were you?
It's literally your job.
I cannot believe I tuned in just in time.
Okay, Rice Nat.
Okay, okay, right.
Okay.
I can't believe you.
Where were you?
I heard them coming.
I was just about to get in the shower and I heard the
screams just want to say rip bozo.
Wow, look how beautiful it was down here.
Whoa, whoa.
Diamond.
Mods band that man.
Where are you?
Who was it?
It was customer Johnson, wasn't it you?
The sent me about Mike?
Right?
I can't believe Mint died of Ligma.
Shut the hell out, Lily, please.
Shut up.
Oh!
We're in...
I don't know!
What's going on?
Ow!
What's that over there?
I think I see the light.
No!
Oh, this is the village that I died!
Hardcore mode is suffering.
What's that down there?
I wonder if we can find something interesting.
Oh, it just looks so square I thought it was like...
The world... Oh, we're back.
Oh, we're back.
We're gone and we're back.
specimen what does that mean what does that even mean that
is so rude i'm more than a specimen literal actual god stop
laughing at me i'm going to what happened why suddenly
creative nothing i got bored of playing the game for real
Well, everybody, oh.
I wonder if it will let me do this.
Stop pausing.
It had to be done.
Did it?
Did it customer support?
Customer support?
Sorry.
You know, usually when you say customer support, I mean,
it's so good.
I'm sorry.
Maybe she changed her name.
Oh god.
To your first or second death, thank you.
Um, wait, back to game.
I'm going now!
But every time I click out of Minecraft, it puts up the...
It does that, so it doesn't, um...
I can't really zoom out.
Um...
Your comedic typing is so perfect and outsider would think
he's a crimson.
What do you mean?
What is that?
Wait, what is that up there?
Do you see that?
Wait, what is that in the sky?
What is that?
Oh my god, it's the village!
It's the best.
I keep seeing these things floating in the sky.
I'm actually crying, you guys.
This isn't funny anymore and I'm tiny and I can't get big.
I'm small and the world is...
See, this is what I'm seeing.
Help me, please.
No.
This is like a like mosquito simulator.
What if I just keep going forever?
Hold on.
This way.
I'm dying now.
I'm dying.
Well, I'm already dead.
I'm dead.
I'm going back to heaven because of my hunt.
Thank you for joining me on this afterlife journey.
Don't fall for, don't fall for the name.
See you in another four years, Mint.
Where are we?
Still in the void, okay.
It's nice and bright up here.
I'm basically toasting I'm frying I'm sizzling Don't go into
the light I am the light I will be a guiding light In your
sad lives So that you Never Say bad things again I'm going
to I wonder where we are.
Like, actually.
I wonder if it'll load.
Aren't she supposed to spectate the world?
I guess it's gone.
Praise the sun.
Doesn't work properly on Java edition yet.
Oh, okay, okay.
Anyway...
That was silly, wasn't it?
That was pretty goofy, wasn't it?
Give pies lots of pets.
Oh, Sumito!
No, no, no, no, no!
Let's make another world.
It doesn't have to be hardcore.
I'm so sad.
Made world Outer Heaven Busted Z!
We'll never be able to go back to you!
That's so sad.
X.
Oh.
It loads so fast.
I feel like I remember in the past.
Worlds used to take, like, a long time to load.
Oh, you're back!
This time...
better than ever
Savannah Oh, I forgot to do the I forgot to put hardcore,
you guys, I forgot to put hardcore I would like to do a
server or join a server I have talked with Henya and Mousy
about maybe if they want to give me a of the maybe the
Vshojo server but it kind of scares me because oh gosh I'm
gonna die like no I'm not I'm not gonna die um it kind of
scares me because like they have they have so many mods um
so I'm a little intimidated by it but we'll see um
we'll see what happens their mod pack is awesome um I've
only watched, like, Kenya play.
And I'm just like, this doesn't even feel like Minecraft.
But it would be fun to try at least.
And I haven't entirely given up on the server of my own
server for people to play.
I just...
I still just don't know.
what to do entirely yet is all make it a hardcore server
that would be so intense wouldn't it
i wonder if there's any armadillos
but yeah so um hopefully next time i play minecraft i just
kind of like i said i wanted to play something that was oh
there's the armadillo I want to play something that was a
little bit more of my comfort since I had a crazy day today.
Um, did you just start a forest flyer?
Now I didn't.
The new wolves are so cute!
They're so sweet.
Little brown dogs.
Little dogs, little dogs.
But yeah, sorry, I'm just kind of like running and I'm
afraid of this ghost.
You shouldn't be...
You shouldn't be real.
Oh my gosh, and there's a jungle right over here.
Maybe we'll get a panda.
Casually sits the forest on fire.
No, these look the same.
Maybe they're a little...
They're a little...
I can't tell.
Are they the same as those dogs?
Ouch.
This is how I make food sometimes.
In Minecraft, obviously.
Don't touch me!
Uh.
Oh.
Come back.
Dang it.
There we go.
See?
Fire pig.
But yeah, like I said, hopefully I will be on a server next
time, whether it be my own or probably most likely somebody
else's.
But yeah.
yeah thank you guys for joining me tonight i know it's a bit
of a shorter stream but um just wanted to kind of hang out a
little bit since i did not stream yesterday for the profile
picture things um i uh um i realized too i also forgot to
put this up but i will in fact rather than having it be like
uh you know pay for me to draw it i'm going to put up like a
google form anybody who's interested and it's gonna be kind
of like more lottery based so um i that way you know you
don't have to be like oh i can't donate a hundred dollars so
um anybody can uh have the chance to get a profile picture
drawn and um gotcha pog yeah but it's free gotcha it's free
gotcha because um yeah
Yeah, yeah.
So, um...
That's what I plan to do.
Um, I think I'll have the stream, uh, on Sunday, since I
didn't do it Sunday.
This time.
I'll do another Sunday.
But what if we want to keep throwing money at you?
Well, that's very generous of you, but I don't want people
to feel like they are always having to throw money at me,
you know?
i just thought like i just thought like i don't know i don't
want to exclude anybody so
dogs no we love it stop so yeah i'll do that and um i wonder
how fast we can get blown up by a creeper hold on i'm gonna
I'm gonna cut down a tree.
We're gonna die.
We're gonna die here.
And we're gonna dig down.
I will aggressively throw money at mint.
No!
Jokes on you, Superjuts are free for the free, gotcha.
Kourisoo!
Thank you for the thank you for the thank you.
But seriously, seriously.
So, um, I don't...
There will probably be quite a bunch of people that, um,
will want to participate.
Oh, wait.
down here um so i'll probably just do like a handful um for
the stream and then um
and then i can do it again another time when i ultimately
don't get to everybody hello where are the where are the bad
guys i'm trapped What was this about free super task?
No, stop throwing what?
Kami-Ku, welcome to membership, thank you!
Someone say free super.
No!
I mean, I certainly did not.
Wait, oh wait, wait!
If I can do this, hold on.
I might be thinking with portals right now.
Oh my gosh, hold on.
Free, free, free.
Wait, hold on.
So...
No way!
I just read it.
I didn't...
No, please.
Okay.
We're gaming.
Yeah, we're gaming.
Okay, here we go.
Time to dig down, baby!
I found time to dig down.
Thank you for the 50 of it!
Thank you!
Oh, we got some coal.
I hear a spider.
Keep going.
Keep going!
Keep going, keep going, keep going.
We hit a mine.
Free.
Why is there a...
Or in Deep Slate.
Why is there a emote that just says free?
Thank you guys for the super chest.
Thank you.
I don't know why you guys are always spoiling me.
I just want to...
If I don't...
I heard... I can't see anything!
Oh!
There's the hole!
Can you guys see anything?
Do you have food?
No, we're here to die, baby.
But I hear lava.
You could make torches.
You're right!
You're still right.
There we go.
Now I can see.
Is it right here?
so dark you guys were gonna die we almost did why is there
an emote that just says free
oh free stuff oh my gosh thank you for the thank you thank
you so much also wait I think there was another one that I
missed earlier hold on another aquasupa i missed earlier
wasn't there oh gosh i'm so sorry i was so distracted by the
the customer and the the mic and everything oh there it is
oh no youtube is um
seori a big aquasupa shared between us the advent fan club
here you go thank you
Thank you so much.
You guys are so goofy.
Advent is lucky to have good fans.
Okay, here we go.
She likes Mike more than us.
Oh, oh.
Spooked me for a second.
I thought it was lava.
I thought we were about to die.
When will we die?
Oh.
Cardamal, thank you for the 50!
Turns out the 20th is free.
Oh!
Uh-oh.
Wait, but I'm supposed to die.
Hold on, let's dig through here.
Into the lava beyond.
S8101010.
It's not free.
It's definitely not free.
What?
I just got the weirdest notification.
Oh, wait.
Oh, I wonder.
Hold on.
You...
Oh, interesting.
I just got a notification.
Okay, so this stream will probably not be monetized.
Because it says we just got...
We just detected audio in your stream belonging to someone
else.
And your stream might be blocked.
No, don't block my stream.
Please.
YouTube.
I'll turn down the jazz.
Is that what's going to do it?
Not the jazz.
you guys we're gonna lose her we're good there it is there
it goes oh wait we can make another okay we can make another
make another
it's from when you sang imagine imagine all the people
Valentine thank you for the 50 okay I think maybe we need to
dig up a little bit if we're still hitting bedrock bring the
workbench with you you're probably right how is it so hard
to die in this game you know
customer Johnson I will not make that I will not be made a
fool twice I will not be made Fool me once!
Shame, shame, shame.
On me.
Valentine, thank you for the birthday!
Oh, I hear the lava.
This way.
Forward.
Oh!
Oh, that was weird.
Come on.
Death said no.
It was so easy for me to die before and become a ghost.
I hear it.
Wait, did that drip?
No.
This is making me nostalgic.
For what?
I wanted to kind of discover like a cool place but dying the
lava I guess is okay too you know if I die I can't oh lava
popping here oh there's a bat there's a bat oh the bat just
burnt I don't know what happened to the bat the bat just
burned the lava lava popping wait what nothing Puddy Puddy
Caves?
Don't say that!
Goodbye, Bat.
She died once.
She can't die twice.
The lava is literally around us.
Please.
Please!
Where are you?
Have you tried slash kill?
I don't have cheats on.
I don't think...
Can you...
Slash kill?
Keep digging.
We'll get there.
We'll get to an opening.
Lava popping, bats are screeching!
Why is it so hard to die in this game?
Is it a buffy?
That sounds right next to me.
The next block I break will be it.
Oh my god.
Where's the lava?
I don't want to die to a skelly.
I don't want to die to your dumbass.
Oh, diamond.
At least we get diamond before we die!
Did it glitch?
That's the wrong axe.
I didn't even think about it.
Because I just always have Like a diamond or iron At least
an iron egg I just always
You know what Okay, Skelly, man You can get me
Come on, put me out of my misery Score one mint one skelly
zero whoa I think I broke minecraft all right since uh since
it doesn't like my late night jazz let's put on some
minecraft music it's like hey hey we detected some music
you're gonna get in trouble minecraft play minecraft you
Play your music.
There it is.
Ah!
That was silly.
In the end, we kind of build a maid cafe.
And we kind of...
No, not at all.
We did find the cherry blossoms.
But we did kind of build a maid cafe.
Well,
it was a pretty useless Minecraft.
Yummy!
Welcome to bamboo ship.
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you.
We've detected audio in your stream belonging to something.
You guys, if this stream gets blocked, I'm so, because of my
jazz, I'm so sorry.
If it gets blocked because of my jazz, I am so sorry.
I thought it'd be fine, but it's okay.
If it just gets demonetized, then it's whatever.
I hope you can join the B-Shoujo server.
I will hopefully have someone to guide me around.
And I don't know.
Any other servers I can join, we'll see.
YouTube does not like jazz.
Not like jazz.
It's so sad.
Haven't they...
Haven't they watched a B-movie?
The cat is finally suing you for all the...
Huh?
My eyes go kind of crazy when I do that.
That's like the, what's it called?
I've seen that girl that does like the...
No Chick-fil-A sauce?
That's how I feel when I did that.
If you don't know what that is, don't worry about it.
We do the noise so well.
Thank you.
Huh?
Well, guys, I'm going to go eat dinner, actually.
Thank you for letting...
Thank you for...
You know, always thank you for letting me just kind of
indulge myself with the dumb things that I like.
You guys let me do stupid Minecraft.
even when it's just me going on a boat listening to jazz and
going through the night and doing nothing i really you guys
are here for no reason but i really appreciate it regardless
um we love dumb things i know sometimes um like people will
be like in minecraft they just like they they don't in it
and that was truly this stream so like sometimes people will
just play Minecraft and just run around and jump and like
just look at stuff but they never do anything and that was
truly this stream but I appreciate you guys watching
regardless even though I wasn't building anything or but
this was my first time like getting into Minecraft in a long
time so It was kind of just nice to...
And I got to see the armadillos and the new wolves.
So that was good.
That was good.
Here for the bits and banter.
Literally here for your doing nothing antics.
I appreciate it.
I really appreciate it.
I don't deserve it.
But I'm very, very, very appreciative.
Thank you, guys.
Tomorrow.
We are not doing nothing.
we are being awesome and cool as hell.
Tomorrow we are.
We are.
We are on the cruise.
Tomorrow.
Oh.
Tomorrow we're being cool.
Tomorrow.
Tomorrow we're being awesome.
Um, oh my goodness, I'm looking at the stream labs now.
What about stream labs ones, though?
Surely those are free.
No!
Built a maid cafe and died.
This is secretly a mint lore stream.
Tomorrow we're being radical and awesome and cool and, um,
Kao Wabunga?
Cool.
I feel like I lost my mind a little bit today's stream so
I'm gonna go check on un pies I'm gonna go make sure she's
all good I've just been kind of trying to make sure she's
I've been like since she was she was since she was in here I
thought I could her the whole time but she wanted to leave
so um she definitely lasted longer in here than butaro
because he never likes to listen to my voice he hates me he
hates me but i'm gonna go check on the little girl make sure
she's okay my little princess otsumito thank you guys
busting busting busting so you guys otsum mic no that guy
deserves no otsu That guy deserves no Otsu.
Bye-bye, y'all.
Get it?
This music's making me sad.
Bye-bye.
Wait, I think my mic might be on because I had to change mic
stuff.
So if you hear me when I do the outro, no, you don't.
did it.
Peace!